[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public la
promesse est dans le titre vous le savez
donner du sens à l'actualité vous
proposez des clés de compréhension des
crises que nous traversons et voici le
sommaire de ce 21 novembre la cop27 se
termine sur un accord d'indemnisation
des pays pauvres pour les dégâts
climatiques qu'il subissent mais pour
l'instant la Chine ne veut pas y
participer ça reste un point de blocage
important parce que la Chine se voit et
se présente encore comme un pays en
développement pour inciter les Chinois à
payer Emmanuel Macron propose un sommet
en juin prochain à Paris que vaut cet
accord de la coop à corps à minima
l'Europe est-elle en avance sur d'autres
régions du monde pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique on en débat
juste après ces titres et puis dans
trois quarts d'heure on se penche sur
l'avenir de la culture et du spectacle
vivant en France moins de public dans
les salles des prêts à rembourser les
prix de l'énergie qui explosent c'est
une équation impossible possible pour
les théâtres privés le constat et des
amorces de solutions de nos experts à
découvrir tout à l'heure mais d'abord
cet accord intitulé pertes et dommages
arraché au prix d'une prolongation de la
coop en Egypte que contient-il pourquoi
ce sommet n'a-t-il pas permis
d'accélérer dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement explication Jonathan
Dupriez beaucoup d'efforts pour un
accord en demi-temps à Charmel Cheikh la
COP 27 s’achève sur une déclaration
finale appelant certes à une réduction
rapide des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mais sans ambition nouvelle par
rapport à la Coop de Glasgow en 2021
ce que nous avons là c'est un pas en
avant mais bien trop court pour les
habitants de la planète cet accord n'est
pas assez contraignant pour pousser les
principaux pays émetteurs de gaz à effet
de serre à plus d'efforts pour réduire
leurs émissions seul avancée de taille
la création d'un fond pour compenser les
dégâts du changement climatique subis
par les pays les plus pauvres une
victoire pour les pays du Sud arraché à
la toute dernière minute grâce au revire
de l'UE puis des États-Unis finalement
favorable au dispositif
même si de toute évidence cela ne
suffira pas c'est un signal politique
indispensable pour reconstruire la
confiance brisée les voies de ceux qui
sont en première ligne de la crise
climatique vont enfin être entendus de
leur côté les ongl aussi salut un
progrès en matière de justice climatique
c'est vraiment une victoire majeure pour
la réponse aux impacts climatiques et
pour la justice climatique puisque la
création de ce mécanisme de financement
pour les pertes dommages je suis
vraiment l'aboutissement d'une lutte de
plus de 30 ans par les pays en
développement pour que enfin les pays
développés puissent contribuer à la
réponse aux impacts climatiques mais la
cop27 restera marquée par cet échec
notable les 186 pays présents ne sont
pas parvenus à s'attaquer aux énergies
fossiles pourtant les principales
responsables du réchauffement climatique
une reculade laissant penser que cette
conférence mondiale sur le climat c'est
davantage d'attaquer aux conséquences de
la crise climatique plutôt qu'à ses
causes je vous présente tout de suite
mes invités Renant dans tech bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sénateur écologiste
de la Loire-Atlantique vice-prés dans la
Commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
ici au Sénat anne-margo bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes coordinatrice des
programmes au Réseau Action Climat
Fergan asiari bonsoir vous êtes
essayiste auteur de ce livre les
écologistes contre la modernité le
procès de Prométhée qui est publié aux
éditions 13 de la cité j'accueille
également Mathieu croissanto bonsoir
Mathieu éditoris politique ce je
rebondis évidemment sur le la principale
annonce de cette cop27 je le disais en
titre fond d'indemnisation des pays les
plus pauvres renants est-ce que c'est
quand même un vrai progrès alors c'est à
la fois un progrès parce que comme ça a
été dit c'était quand même très attendu
très demandé par les pays les plus
vulnérables depuis longtemps donc il
fallait ce signal mais je crois que
c'est pas encore financé et que surtout
je pense que l'Europe on a fait le
cheval 1 2 3 le levier pour remettre en
cause ce qui est le socle de la
convention depuis Rio c'est-à-dire cette
fameuse Lite ce qu'on appelle dans le
jargon de la Coop annexe 1 c'est-à-dire
les pays industrialisés qui doivent
payer pour leur responsabilité commune
mais différenciée par rapport à des pays
qui sont aujourd'hui considérés comme
des pays en développement qui donc ne
payent pas comme le Qatar comme la Chine
et l'Europe a été très claire en disant
ok pour le fond mais on le financera
tous et la Chine a tout de suite répondu
non donc je pense qu'en fait c'est
peut-être une COP historique de la fin
finalement du monde de Rio ça ouvre une
nouvelle ère ça ouvre à mon avis une
nouvelle ère ou aujourd'hui il faut que
tous ceux qui participent réellement au
réchauffement dont la Chine 14 % des
émissions historiques quand même la
Chine aujourd'hui des classes moyennes
qui émettent plus que les classes
moyennes européennes que la Chine est
effectivement devient aussi un
contributeur et de fait alliez pas prête
de ce qu'on entend depuis vous vous y
étiez à cette cop il a vraiment été
arraché de justesse cette cet accord il
y a une prolongation de 24 heures est-ce
que c'est un peu comme quand il y a des
négociations sociales en France où il y
a là il y a la mise en scène de la nuit
au niveau européen la nuit de veille
pour arriver à la Corse toujours j'ai
toujours connu la dernière nuit du
théâtre les portes qui claquent mais je
crois que c'est quand même extrêmement
important ce que l'Europe a dit je
trouve que l'Europe a assez bien joué en
disant maintenant ça suffit on arrête
avec le monde finalement des Non Alignés
de la période soviétique ce n'est plus
le monde réel donc il va falloir
discuter du monde réel ça va entraîner
une négociation très très dure parce que
derrière c'est des centaines de milliers
qui sont sur la table donc qui va
financer les pertes et préjudice comment
va se passer demain et l'OMC va émettre
un premier avis là-dessus l'arrivée de
la taxe carbone aux frontières de
l'Union européenne permise par justement
l'engagement européen de baisse le moins
55 ou moins 57% des émissions on rentre
dans un monde qui va être extrêmement
extrêmement dur dans les négociations
mais je crois il fallait passer par là
donc cette comme là dessus peut-être un
succès même si les résultats les verra
dans deux trois ans un bringo se font la
perte des dommages c'était une
revendication des associations des ONG
depuis longtemps depuis des décennies
quasiment pourquoi il faut imaginer on
est comme dans une copropriété vous avez
créé un dégât des eaux il y a une grosse
fuite d'eau depuis des années et puis
les gens de l'appartement du dessous
l'appartement il est totalement dévasté
et vous refusez de payer pour les dégâts
causés c'est ça le problème c'est que
les pays du Nord ont émis des gaz à
effet de serre qui ont créé changement
climatique qui créent les sécheresses
les inondations la montée du niveau des
mers dans des pays qui n'ont pas causé
ce changement climatique l'Afrique c'est
4% des émissions mondiales et les pays
qui ont causé ces émissions de gaz à
effet de serre disent ben non on va pas
payer les dégâts donc là disait voilà
donc maintenant ils disent ok sur le
principe donc reste à voir qui va payer
est-ce que ce sont les pays plus
émetteur historiquement est-ce que la
Chine qui aimait beaucoup maintenant
doit payer mais les dégâts ils sont
causés depuis des décennies donc il faut
quand même regarder qui est responsable
des émissions depuis ces décennies qui
va toucher cet argent et ce que ce sont
les pays les plus vulnérables ou est-ce
que le Pakistan par exemple qui a vécu
des inondations dramatique va pouvoir
percevoir ses financements et quel sera
le montant puisque comme le disait au
nom nantais qu'on parle de centaines de
milliards de dollars par an c'est des
montants considérables donc on peut
supposer que les mois à venir vont être
assez houleux au niveau des discussions
[Musique]
on s'est appuyait beaucoup sur le
charbon qui est très très émetteur de
gaz à effet de serre et tout ça accumulé
fait que les États-Unis restent de loin
le pays le plus émetteur bien avant la
Chine asiari est-ce que vous aussi vous
y voyez un progrès que pensez-vous de ce
fond d’anémisation écoutez ce fonds une
bonne idée c'est à dire que c'est ce
qu'on a expliqué tout à l'heure les
externalités négatives qui ont été
historiquement générés par les pays
riches méritent en effet un mécanisme de
compensation maintenant il faut bien
comprendre que c'est quand même un
pansement sur une jambe de bois et qu'on
traite davantage les symptômes que les
causes moi il y a une chose qui me gêne
c'est que parmi les causes des de la
vulnérabilité et des pays pauvres il y a
aussi la question du sous-développement
qui n'est pas abordé c'est-à-dire que on
sait aujourd'hui que la le succès des
pays face au changement climatique
dépend aussi des trajectoires de
développement économique et
technologique quand vous vous appelez
Israël et que vous avez les moyens de
dessaler l'eau de mer vous êtes beaucoup
moins vulnérable sécheresse que lorsque
vous appelez Madagascar quand vous vous
appelez les Pays-Bas et que vous avez
les moyens d'avoir des dispositifs de
protection côtière ultra sophistiquées
vous êtes davantage que vous êtes moins
vulnérable à la montée des eaux ni aux
inondations que lorsque vous appelez le
Bangladesh or la question de la
trajectoire du développement économique
et technologique n'est pas posé puisque
madame cet argent pourra servir à ça
alors pourra servir à ça s'il est bien
employé en effet mais vous savez l'aide
publique développement ça fait des
décennies qu'on en parle ça fait des
décennies que beaucoup d'économistes
malheureusement constatent son
inefficacité en raison des mécanismes de
corruption en raison de tout un tas de
choses qui font que ce développement
industriel est insuffisant madame disait
tout à l'heure que ça fait des décennies
qu'on parle de ce mécanisme je trouve
que cet argument il est aussi révélateur
quelque part d'un échec c'est-à-dire que
comment se fait-il que pendant des
décennies beaucoup de pays notamment du
Sud ont été incapables d'amorcer leur
décollage industriel pour s'armer
davantage pour bien comprendre nos
responsabilité des pays du Sud si je
comprends bien je pense qu'il y a aussi
effectivement matière à interpeller les
pays du Sud pour comprendre comment leur
incurie les maintiennent les maintiens
pardon dans le sous-développement je
prends juste un exemple prenez un pays
comme la Corée du Sud il y a encore 60
ans la Corée du Sud avait un PIB par
habitant inférieur à l'Afrique
subsaharienne inférieur à l'Afrique
subsaharienne aujourd'hui la Corée du
Sud est une locomotive de l'économie
mondiale ce pays est même en train
d'exporter des réacteurs nucléaires au
pays émergents donc c'est un un une arme
aussi pour lutter contre le changement
climatique or vous avez plein de pays
qui sont à la traîne et me semble qu'on
peut pas simplement se poser la question
de enfin envisager le rapport Nord-Sud à
travers le prisme de la charité sans
poser aussi la question c'est de la
réparation sans poser la question très
bien mais sans poser la question aussi
de la persistance du sous-développement
dans un certain nombre de pays ce qui
pose la question de la responsabilité
aussi des élus des pays du Sud n'est pas
suffisamment interrogé me semble-t-il
dans ces instances multilatéraux moi
j'avais une question est-ce qu'on parle
d'une indemnité qui serait versée ou
est-ce qu'on parle de financement de
projets pour mener la transition en gros
est-ce que c'est un chèque ou est-ce que
c'est un silence de
projets
dommages donc c'est quasiment ça c'est
payé pour des dégâts causés et ce n'est
pas effectivement un fond pour le
développement mais il y a d'autres fonds
qui avaient été prévu des Copenhague en
2009 comme précédente pour l'atténuation
donc la baisse des émissions gaz à effet
de serre et là effectivement on peut
aller vers un développement plus vert et
vers l'adaptation donc comment faire
évoluer son agriculture ces
infrastructures pour résister à un
climat qui dans tous les cas change donc
c'est vrai qu'il y a plusieurs fonds
hier c'est un fond où on versera une
indemnité au gouvernement des pays
concernés ça se passera comment on ne
sait pas encore c'est à dire en fait
comment on va la définir quoi comment
dire tel pays à droite c'est un cadre de
départ la négociation va commencer on a
mis en place à Sharm el shake à un
comité de mise en place de ce fond
comment on fait pour tous les fonds donc
c'est c'est c'est l'habitude de l'ONU et
ce comité va travailler au moins deux
ans avant de faire des des propositions
et comme on sait qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui les les nouveaux grands
émetteurs ne sont pas prêts à financer
je pense que ça va être assez assez
tendu généralement il y a toujours un
compromis à la fin mais comme le dit un
bringo il faut bien voir qu'il y a un
premier engagement des pays développés à
Copenhague 2009 c'était ça c'est-à-dire
quand même 13 ans
à l'engagement les fameux 100 milliards
après le dîner chez l'arrêt qui n'a pas
été tenu et ça c'est un vrai problème
dans la confiance entre le Nord et le
Sud puisque on est toujours à 82
milliards on atteint pas les 100
milliards c'est fondamentalement la
faute des États-Unis la France
globalement en termes de pourcentage à
fait sa part donc ça ça a quand même
beaucoup fragilisé la Coop qui est par
définition une recherche de consensus
bon donc ça c'est un fait de confiance
il y a une paire de confiance
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui je crois
que effectivement il faut faire pression
sur la Chine sur les pays arabes en
disant vous avez aussi une part de la
responsabilité historique quand vous
éteignez 14 % des émissions pour la
Chine 14% pour les économies du Sud-Est
exotique c'est les 28% des États-Unis
donc historiquement on arrive
pratiquement au même masse entre l'Asie
l'Europe et les États-Unis aujourd'hui
c'est plus discutable oui mais en termes
historique on arrive à peu près au même
donc il faut à la fois de la Chine
change sa logique et ça ça va être très
compliqué mais il faut aussi que des
États-Unis assument enfin l'engagement
pris en 2009 et ils ne tiennent toujours
pas alors ça va être difficile tel qu'il
est sur la Chine on y revient tout de
suite et je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait de l'interview du ministre de
l'économie ce matin sur France Info on
en a vu un cours passage dans dans nos
titres donc il reconnecte à se complique
en terme de financement et de pays qui
acceptent de de payer nos confrères lui
demande est-ce que la Chine devra
abonder ses fonds d'animation ça reste
un point de blocage important parce que
la Chine se voit et se présente encore
comme un pays en développement ils
disent sur des critères qui datent de
198 arguments à l'appui nous nous sommes
plus d'un milliard d'habitants nous ont
encore un taux de pauvreté qui est
important la Chine est aussi un des
principaux émetteurs de CO2 au monde
donc la Chine a une responsabilité sur
le climat qui est un responsabilité très
lourde c'est pour cela que le
rendez-vous de 2023 proposé par le
Président de la République est décisif
il faut que les grands États la Chine en
premier puisse prendre ses
responsabilités pour ça il faut un lieu
pour en débattre ce sera le lieu de
cette conférence du financement du
climat alors effectivement conférence de
financement du climat annoncé par
Emmanuel Macron sur Twitter on va on va
lire les propos du président de la
République lors de la cop27 la France et
l'Europe ont réaffirmé leur engagement
pour le climat nous avons besoin d'un
nouveau pacte financier avec les pays
les plus vulnérables j'y travailler avec
nos partenaires en vue d'un sommet à
Paris avant la prochaine
COP double question feria asiari d'abord
ce sommet est le fait que voilà il se
déroule en France qu'Emmanuel Macron
tente de prendre une sorte de leadership
sur l'organisation qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez et puis ensuite effectivement
quel sens est-ce que c'est pas l'échec
d'un d'un dispositif l'échec annoncé
d'un dispositif si la Chine y participe
pas c'est en effet un risque d'échec si
les la Chine les pays émergents de
manière générale ou de se ce rendez-vous
mais tout va dépendre de la manière dont
les pays du Nord finalement traitent ce
phénomène et tout dépend de leur
discours parce que si vous voulez moi ce
qui m'étonne un petit peu c'est la
surprise des commentateurs des riches
qui se désole de la réticence des pays
du Sud pardon mais aussi longtemps que
nous ne comprendrons pas qu'il n'y a
rien de plus indécent si vous voulez
d'arriver face aux Chinois aux Indiens
aux Africains et de leur dire simplement
arrêter d'aimer des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre sans leur donner de
solutions alternatives pour se
développer sans recourir à ces énergies
fossiles aussi longtemps que nous
tiendrons un discours exclusivement
culpabilisateur sans sans proposer de
solutions concrètes nous susciterons
nous ne susciterons que de la réticence
de la part de ces pays-là donc il faut
aussi que les pays du Nord trouvent et
c'est vrai de la Chine d'aujourd'hui ça
se ce l'argument que vous vous portez le
PIB par habitant de la Chine faut pas
seulement regarder la Chine dans son
ensemble
il me semble quatre fois inférieur à
celui de la France aujourd'hui donc en
effet c'est un pays qui est encore
légitime à se considérer comme un pays
émergent ceci dit la Chine est aussi en
mesure à la aujourd'hui une avance
technologique et considérable qui lui
permet par exemple d'être de prendre des
mesures ambitieuses en matière de de
d'énergie décarbonée donc elle a aussi
déjà
les pays riches du fait de leur
responsabilité historique et du fait de
leur statut de leur de des moyens
technologiques économiques dont ils
disposent aujourd'hui ont une
responsabilité aussi qui est celle qui
consiste à dire et bien nous nous avons
des solutions technologiques à vous
proposer on va investir dans vos pays
pour décarboner votre industrie vous
délivrez à la fois de la misère et des
énergies fossiles mais si on arrive avec
un discours c'est pour ça que vous
prenez l'exemple de la Corée du Sud par
exemple qui arrive avec ces centrales
nucléaires et l'exemple parfait c'est le
modèle à suivre c'est un pays qui a un
programme très ambitieux en matière
d'exportation d'énergie nucléaire donc
ils vont stocker à la porte des
Jordaniens des émiratis des Polonais des
Brésiliens et ils leur disent voilà vous
voulez de l'énergie des carbonée on vous
en donne et ça une quadruple vertue à la
fois économique environnemental
économique parce que rapidement en
enrichissant les pays du Sud on enrichit
de l'humanité mais aussi
environnementale puisque en réduisant
les émissions internes des pays en voie
de développement et bien vous réduisez
aussi vos émissions importées donc le
jeu mutuellement profitable et on a tout
intérêt à le mettre en oeuvre davantage
enfin c'est pas le nucléaire coréen qui
va stabiliser le climat planétaire ça
c'est assez évident en terme quantitatif
il y a beaucoup de questions sur la
table donc et chacune de ces questions
mérite des heures de débat on va pas
avoir le temps de plusieurs questions
quand même alors même si on essaye de
nos experts chinoise
urbaine aujourd'hui et mettent par
habitant et ça c'est parfaitement
documenté plus de CO2 que les classes
moyennes européennes ça aujourd'hui pas
moyen
parce que effectivement la Chine reste
beaucoup à de ces classes moyennes la
population chinoise dans son ensemble la
population chinoise rurale sert à
baisser le bilan mais quand on regarde
comment on vit à Shanghai comment on vit
dans les Chinoises mais plus de CO2
vers la transition chinoise va moins
vite parce que il y a encore énormément
de charbon il y a aussi le fait de la
Chine qui fait des efforts sur le
renouvelable ça c'est évident
à un problème cette année et ça c'est il
y a un excellent rapporte time vous
pouvez aller sur le site qui qui essaye
de décrire l'évolution des émissions on
voit par exemple que la baisse de la
pluviométrie la baisse de l'eau
disponible dans les barrages entraîner
un pic des émissions en Chine au Brésil
parce qu'il a fallu reprendre du charbon
du gaz en terme de production électrique
mais on a effectivement sur les
émergents aujourd'hui des évolutions
assez intéressantes la France
effectivement joue un rôle assez leader
alors il suffira pas que Emmanuel Macron
convoque un sommet pour qu'on stabilise
les flux financiers l'échelle planétaire
on est bien d'accord mais ce soleil a
besoin
intéressant vis-à-vis des émergences ce
qui avait été vu à Glasgow l'année
dernière ou les banques de développement
occidental propose finalement des prêts
à l'Afrique du Sud et des prix
conséquents plusieurs milliards pour
sortir de l'économie du charbon ça a été
calé là aussi un accord avec l'Indonésie
de la même manière à cette coque le
problème principal qu'on a c'est que moi
je suis extrêmement inquiet pour
l'Afrique la Chine elle-même a dit
qu'elle ne financerait plus le charbon
africain que sur le renouvelable la
Chine l'Afrique décroche c'est vraiment
un Epsilon des investissements sur le
renouvelable et que si ça continue comme
ça on va avoir effectivement les pays
occidentaux les grands émergents qui
continuent de se développer mais une
Afrique qui ne trouve plus le
financement de sa transition énergétique
pourquoi et cette question là est
vraiment sur la il faut sur la table de
raisons pour pour cela mais moi je suis
assez inquiet de ce qu'on voit
d'un risque de décrochage encore plus
fort de de l'Afrique si on ne trouve pas
les financements et notamment le fond
vert servait à ça
et beaucoup plus élevé que en Europe ou
ailleurs donc c'est vrai que parce que
c'est peut-être des pays qui présente
plus de risques alors financiers et donc
finalement on prête un taux et donc
clairement là il y a un rôle à jouer
effectivement pour les perriches de les
accompagner dans ces investissements
alors pour l'instant les fonds apporter
les fameux 100 milliards qui sont 83
milliards c'est essentiellement des
prêts c'est vrai que les pays riches
prêtes beaucoup d'argent notamment pour
aller à renouvelables le problème c'est
que ce sont des pays déjà endettés alors
on rajoute de la dette sur de la dette
et ça ne les aide pas vraiment il faut
davantage de dons il faut que
effectivement les aider aussi sur les
images donc voilà mais on n'a pas parlé
aussi d'autres je le suspecte c'est les
pays producteurs d'hydrocarbures qui ont
quand même freiné beaucoup cette j'ai
prévu d'en parler
en Égypte la prochaine se passe à Dubaï
donc c'est pas forcément très rassurant
l'action contre le changement climatique
j'espère qu'on aura le temps dans dans
dire un mot alors on parlait de
d'Emmanuel Macron qui va organiser
Mathieu cette ce sommet du financement à
Paris au mois de juin alors Emmanuel
Macron il reçoit ce soir des chefs
d'entreprise ça va être intéressant et
là aussi on va parler de transition
énergétique oui parce que c'est une
équation complexe pour le président qui
va devoir retrouver son mantra favori du
et en même temps car c'est bien beau de
vouloir s'afficher comme le champion de
la transition écologique de la
transition énergétique enfin je dis
c'est bien beau c'est nécessaire bien
évidemment je plaisante mais encore
faut-il que cela ne se traduise pas en
naufrage industriel ou naufrage
économique pour le président donc les
équipes multiplient les gestes à
destination des entreprises à la fois
pour les aider pour les rassurer et pour
leur offrir ce qu'elle adorent ce
qu'elles veulent le plus de la
visibilité pour faire face pour les
aider
l'exécutif à ressorti le carnet de
chèque pour faire face à la crise
énergétique celle c'est la crise du
moment en mettant 10 milliards d'euros
d'aide sur la table avec des critères
assouplis des procédures raccourcis
histoire de les toucher le plus vite
possible c'est un geste qui était très
attendu par le secteur industriel en
particulier qui a vu sa facture
énergétique multipliée alors les les
estimations varient mais entre par 3 ou
par 4 depuis 2019 ça c'est pour
maintenant c'est à dire pour aider les
entreprises qui menacent de mettre la
clé sous la porte à cause de la former
les prix d'énergie
[Musique]
à toutes ces entreprises le chef de
l'État entend demandé de rester car s'il
y a des industries qui menacent de
mettre la clé sous la porte et aussi
celle de qui menace de quitter l'Europe
et pourquoi elle quitte l'Europe à cause
de well qui trait d'Europe à cause de
l'inflation énergétique ça c'est une
chose mais aussi parce que quand on est
un chef d'entreprise européen bah on
regarde un peu où est-ce qu'on est le
mieux accueilli dans le monde et les
États-Unis s'apprêtent à débourser une
somme absolument considérable pour
financer un énorme plan d'investissement
pour la transition énergétique et
écologique au sens large cette fois-ci
367 milliards d'euros c'est un chiffre
qui fait trembler en Europe ou on
s'insurge contre ce qui apparaît comme
de la des concurrence déloyale dans
cette guerre de la transition écologique
mais en Europe on se paye souvent de
mots parce qu'on est incapable de
riposter il y a eu des propositions de
joué à peine by Act vous savez pour
essayer de faire du protectionnisme à
l'européenne mais ça reste encore une
forme de gros mots pour la souveraineté
alors sur cette capacité à résister à ce
plan d'investissement parce que c'est
c'est faramineux effectivement 3 37
milliards d'euros Ronan dansait
qu'est-ce que l'Europe c'est l'une des
questions que je souhaitais aborder dans
ce débat est-ce que l'Europe a la
capacité à devenir une sorte de de
moteur de de la transformation
énergétique ou environnementale de monde
parce que je le disais tout à l'heure en
introduction le plan européen le feed
for fifty-five gagne un effort assez
colossal moins 55% des missions de CO2
en 2030 c'est c'est énormément
d'investissement et de vrais mutation ça
va avec une taxe carbone aux frontières
dont on ne veulent pas les chinois dont
ne veulent pas les Américains mais
l'Europe c'est très bien et qu'elle ne
peut pas faire cet effort si ça
décarbonation si elle se protège pas son
marché intérieur justement on est dans
les mots ou dans les actes
du tout l'OMC doit rendre un premier
avis l'Organisation mondiale du commerce
sur cette taxe carbone aux frontières
qui est permise justement parce qu'il y
a le fit for fifty on le dit pas assez
sur le fil de forfait parce que sans ce
plan européen on ne peut pas just auprès
de l'OMC doit se rajouter une tasse
carbone aux frontières donc ça ça va
changer beaucoup les choses on est là
aussi on est dans deux niveaux un moment
de crise où on prend à peu près tout ce
qui est disponible par exemple en gaz en
gaz de schiste qui ont une empreinte
carbone proche du seul charbon c'est à
peu près le même niveau d'émission de
CO2 entre gaz de schiste et le charbon
donc ça c'est dans la crise actuelle
pour pas casser la machine et demain par
contre très clairement ça veut dire que
ces gaz de schiste avec leur empreinte
carbone seront très très indéfavorisés
sur le marché européen par rapport à des
y compris à des gaz normaux donc non
l'Europe n'est pas quand même le ravi de
la crèche mais pas oui oui aux
États-Unis on peut avoir des aides
directes pour acheter une voiture
électrique américaine est-ce que
l'Europe peut mettre en place favoriser
les achats de produits européens
autrement que par
cette pour l'instant c'est pas le faire
c'est vrai que pour relier avec la COP
ce qu'on a pas trouvé dans la Coop il y
a des financements des dégâts du
changement climatique il y a pas les
moyens de réduire ces dégâts en
réduisant les émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et il y aura pas parce qu'il y
a des pays qui bloquent notamment les
pays de producteurs d'hydrocarbures donc
ça il va falloir le faire chez nous en
France en Europe effectivement il y a
des moyens pour l'industrie lourde et
sur l'industrie lourde finalement ça
avance pas si mal en France parce que
c'est quelques sites on sait faire on va
transformer les technologies par contre
sur la mobilité là on n'a pas réellement
les solutions Emmanuel Macron avait une
seule mesure dans son programme
électoral un leasing de 100 euros pour
un véhicule électrique pour les ménages
de bas revenus est-ce que vous l'avez vu
arriver c'est prévu
24 dans quelques territoires pourquoi de
toute façon pour l'instant ça ça fait
acheter aux Français des véhicules
chinois donc
ne veulent pas fabriquer des petits
véhicules électriques parce qu'il ne
marchent pas dessus il n'y a pas de
marge donc là l'état il va falloir quand
même qu'il fasse quelque chose pour
effectivement inciter fortement les
constructeurs automobiles à produire des
véhicules qui sont utiles à la
population française et européenne
c'est-à-dire des petits véhicules
électriques on pourrait parler aussi des
investissements dans le ferroviaire on
attend vraiment des montants importants
là-dessus pour pouvoir d'avoir des
alternatives à la voiture des choses sur
le vélo la rénovation des logements pour
réduire la facture énergétique ça c'est
un levier ultra efficace donc voilà
maintenant c'est chez nous qui va
falloir faire ses actions pour réduire
vraiment notre consommation d'énergie et
la facture énergétique de la France qui
est énorme attention quand même au
discours protectionniste parce que moi
ce discours là m'inquiète aussi parce
que je rappelle que la transition
écologique c'est quand même un chantier
coûteux qui était davantage accessible
au pays riches au pays pauvres et casser
la mondialisation et donc freiner
l'enrichissement des pays pauvres je ne
suis pas sûr que c'est la meilleure
manière de leur donner des armes
nécessaires pour investir sur la Chine
oui je voudrais qu'il soit moins pauvre
je voudrais qu'il soit moins pauvre je
voudrais qu'il soit moins pauvre pour
davantage davantage investir dans leur
transition écologique
le climat ça va mal finir
compati monsieur puisque encore une fois
vous pouvez tout à fait utiliser la
mondialisation pour investir dans la
décarbonation des pays du Sud le marché
des capitaux
économie monde le marché le marché des
capitaux là qui permet d'investir donc
je pense que il faut utiliser la
mondialisation pour décarboner les
économistes émergentes mais en revanche
si attention on revient dans une logique
de guerre commerciale et de
protectionnisme qui appauvrit tout
l'humanité en guerre commerciale si on
revient si on joue cette logique de
guerre commerciale jusqu'au bout et
qu'on casse à mondialisation et donc
qu'on réduit l'enrichissement de
l'humanité je ne suis pas sûr qu'on
permette à la plupart de ces pays de
s'armer face au changement attention à
rejoindre dans un texte c'est à dire que
les autres la pratique la guerre
commerciale donc il faut bien que il
faut bien que l'Europe il faut bien que
l'Europe dans le piège que vous devez
faire la même chose c'est pas parce que
des bêtises que des fois la même chose
c'est pas parce que pardon je vais
prendre un exemple un peu caricatural
mais c'est pas parce que des pays sont
complètement autarciques qu'il faut les
imiter donc non au contraire c'est les
pays émergents sont des pays qui
généralement n'ont pas beaucoup
d'épargne de capitaux donc les pays
riches qui sont régulièrement accusés en
excès d'épargne et capitaux
investir davantage pour accélérer le
processus pourquoi freiner pourquoi
freiner les efforts existants
n'étant très ouvert à tout vent on a vu
avec la crise sanitaire puis la crise
énergétique qui avait probablement un
enjeu de millions d'êtres humains qui
ont été sortis de la pauvreté par la
mondialisation et qui verrait le
rétention
on est parti très très loin je crois
qu'il faut revenir effectivement sur la
sur la Coop mais c'est en lien avec ces
lieux c'est à dire en clair je crois que
l'Europe c'est pour moi c'est une COP
presque historique ça paraît pas comme
ça dans le résultat parce qu'on a pas
stabilisé le climat mais l'Europe a dit
clairement on ne joue plus on remet en
cause la base de Rio la convention donc
ça fait effectivement tousser beaucoup
les Chinois voir les Américains derrière
qui jouent un jeu toujours assez
compliqué l'Europe mais effectivement
sa puissance économique à travers la
taxe carbone au service d'une
mondialisation régulée c'est ça ce qui
est en train de se jouer c'est la
principale chance du climat c'est-à-dire
de dire si vous voulez avoir accès au
marché européen demain il faudra faire
un effort sur le climat certains le font
un pays comme l'Indonésie par exemple
car longtemps été montré du doigt sur la
question de la déforestation c'est quand
même l'huile de palme enfin vous voyez
bien les débats qu'on a pu avoir
l'Indonésie aujourd'hui a des résultats
de sur sa baisse de déforestation très
intéressante et derrière on arrive c'est
un des accords chères mécède avec des
financements pour la sortir de
l'économie du charbon ça c'est un thé
rapidement c'est à dire qu'on peut
inverser une une spirale négative
rapidement pour le surprend l'exemple de
l'ayote de l'Indonésie oui enfin le
rapidement c'est pas six mois c'est
quand même on est globalement
je pense qu'on est vraiment sur une
décennie de changement de modèle on a
une COP très importante qui arrive aussi
ça c'est un des acquis de cette coop
c'est qu'avec l'arrivée de Lula on aura
une cop
Amazonie qui sera une coop autour de la
reconquête de la France la prochaine est
à Dubaï c'est ça donc
au Brésil ça sera la COP d'accord
et y compris avec des flux financiers de
compensation qui font débat mais qui
seront certainement captés par la
reconquête forestière on est dans un
monde qui bouge moi je suis pas je suis
contre le Climatop fatalisme ça va pas
assez vite on est tous d'accord il faut
que la France se prépare un plus 4
degrés je le dis dans d'autres enceintes
avec ma casquette de président du comité
d'orientation du programme d'adaptation
nationale mais c'est quand même un monde
qui bouge jusqu'à qu'on arrivera ni à ni
à ennemi ça c'est mort ni à donner à
trois vous dites + 4,5
j'ai compris
la pente est extrêmement raide si on
poursuit les émissions comme
actuellement on atteint degré 5 en
2037-2015
faut vivre la période de du premier
confinement pendant 5 ans c'est ça en
terme d'activité extrêmement
dresseur
d'avoir en tête que un chaque dixième de
degré compte c'est pas un sujet léger
c'est aussi si on passe à 2 degrés c'est
55 millions de personnes en plus qui
souffrent de la fin en Afrique donc
c'est pas léger donc il faut vraiment
effectivement des transformations
radicales on se rend peut-être pas
compte à quel point c'est transformation
sont radicales mais elles sont
nécessaires si on dépasse un peu un
degré 5 l'idée c'est de rebaisser d'ici
à la fin du siècle pour revenir en
dessous de 1 degré 5 donc il faut
surtout pas lâcher l'affaire et
5 même si on passe par un peu plus haut
j'apporte à ce débat une autre réaction
celle
le député socialiste de l'Essonne à
propos de ce fonds d'indemnisation
Jérôme Guedj j'ai dit cette cop27 c'est
un échec et se font et même le
révélateur de l'échec on l'écoute ce
fond là c'est d'une certaine manière en
creux le révélateur de l'échec
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'arrive pas à
interdire les énergies fossiles dans une
coque mais évidemment mais sauf que vous
voyez que là on est déjà dans la
catastrophe j'entendais tout à l'heure
une image très parlante c'est comme si
sur le Titanic au moment où on a percuté
l'iceberg on allait indemniser les
passagers de troisième classe je vais
dire que c'est pas ça dont on a besoin
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui le réchauffement
climatique c'est la menace absolue et on
a le lobbying la pression de ces pays
producteurs d'énergie fossile c'était le
cas en Égypte et quand on sait que la
prochaine COP elle aura lieu à Dubaï en
2023 on s'est dit que nous n'avons pas
pris la mesure
on est sur le Titanic on se prépare à
indemniser les passagers de troisième
classe l'image à ma Go elle est elle est
frappante elle est pas loin d'être juste
parce qu'effectivement le Titanic ben
Nicolas Hulot on avait parlé il avait
fait un film sur le sujet c'est une
image qu'on reprend souvent je pense que
maintenant en fait on est rentré dans
l'iceberg il y a quelques années on
aurait pu dire il pouvait en pouvant
encore dévier maintenant voilà on est
rentré dedans la question c'est comment
on arrive effectivement à faire qui est
le moins de mort et donc effectivement
là il y a un financement des dégâts
parce qu'il y a des gens qui sont déjà
malheureusement
très mal en point mais par contre on
peut encore quand même sauver la plupart
des personnes et donc réduire les
émissions et c'est vrai que c'est ça
l'enjeu c'est pas seulement de financer
des dégâts mais c'est de réduire ses
dégâts et cette réduction là
malheureusement ça a coincé à Chamal
cherche pas du tout d'accord avec Jérôme
gage mais c'est pas je reprends son
argumentation c'est à dire que
effectivement on dit là cette COP on
peut considérer qu'elle ait réussi parce
que il y a eu la décision d'ouvrir ce
fond d'indemnisation même si on l'a bien
expliqué on sait pas encore qui va payer
et comment mais c'est un peu voilà
l'arbre qui cache la forêt d'un accord
qui n'a pas été alors peut-être
d'ailleurs qu'il était même pas sur la
table de négociation mais c'est pas
c'est pas une raison sur le la
limitation du réchauffement il s'est
rien passé en terme de démission de gaz
à effet de serre d'engagement pour aller
plus vite dans la
réductions c'est vrai que ça fait 15 ans
que je suis l'école des effets de
plateau sur le climat mais moi j'ai dû
en faire un certain nombre vous en
trouverez c'est facile de faire un effet
de plateau sur le climat c'est facile
d'utiliser l'image du Titanic dans un
sens ou dans l'autre c'est pas la
question cette COP c'est pas une
réussite c'est pas un échec c'est le
début d'un mécanisme mais si cette
pardon nous interrompre si cette COP ne
sert pas aux États à prendre des
engagements plus profond plus et donc de
manière plus rapide
si on considère que ça n'est pas allé
assez vite
national en réalité c'est à dire que le
fait que le pétrole et le gaz ne soit
pas dans un texte qui du changement
climatique et ça depuis le début des
cops c'est quand même un problème vous
disiez les pays producteurs l'Arabie
Saoudite la Russie l’égypte pays haute
qui produit beaucoup de gaz et l'année
prochaine à Dubaï ça va être pareil donc
on voit bien que le processus produit
réellement de baisser les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre ils ont ils
montrent ses limites et c'est là où je
vous rejoins l'accord de Paris qu'est-ce
qu'il a créé il a créé le fait que ça
soit finalement au niveau des États que
ça doit se passer c'est maintenant les
États qui eux feront on contribution
donc au niveau européen c'est l'Europe
qui apporte une contribution et c'est
bien là où on doit baisser les émissions
parce que attendre la COP
révolutionnaire où on pourra dire qu'il
faut baisser les les la consommation de
gaz et de pétrole ça serait logique ça
serait du point de vue scientifique
juste mais il y a trop de blocages y
compris par des lobbies très des
entreprises pétrolières et gazières qui
n'ont aucune envie de voir ses mentions
dans un accord international donc c'est
vraiment au niveau national et au niveau
des collectivités qu'il faut agir et on
a les leviers pour agir sur la mobilité
sur le chauffage sur l'agriculture sur
l'industrie donc il faut pas attendre la
prochaine COP il faut commencer dès
maintenant faire un asiari c'est au
niveau national ou au niveau européen
les deux je pense que le pouvoir
aujourd'hui est entre les mains des
États-nations donc c'est eux qui ont
Infiné le dernier mot ensuite à eux de
créer les coopérations et les dynamiques
multilatérales nécessaires pour
décarboner l'économie mondiale
maintenant pour revenir au blocage il
faut comprendre aussi la psychologie des
pays émergents moi je voudrais qu'on
fasse preuve davantage d'empathie si
vous voulez bien c'est à dire que le
problème des blocages vient du fait que
chaque fois qu'un pays émergent entend
on va réduire vos émissions de gaz à
effet de serre il entend on va vous
assigner à la misère perpétuelle donc il
faut aussi rassurer ces pays réaffirmer
Larabie Saoudite la misère perpétuelle
je parle
[Musique]
remettre en place un droit de veto des
mers sur l'installation de ces éoliennes
mais aussi des panneaux solaires et
d'autres infrastructures de production
d'énergie renouvelables il avait déjà
fait lors de précédentes c'est pour ça
qu'on s'en doute et on faut le dire le
Sénat chambre des territoires est élu à
plus de 90 % par des mères aux élections
sénatoriales mais alors finalement en
séance c'est un peu un coup de théâtre
qu'on a vu le 3 novembre les sénateurs
votent finalement un compromis avec le
gouvernement exit le droit de veto pour
laisser place à un autre dispositif on
parle maintenant de zone prioritaire
d'implantation de ces infrastructures
avec un avis conforme du Conseil
municipal le maire fixe des priorités
sur chaque type d'énergie renouvelable
mais ne peut plus s'opposer projet par
projet alors le dispositif doit encore
être éclairci la ministre règne espagnol
une hachée l'a dit en séance vous allez
faire l'objet d'éclaircissement au fil
de la navette parlementaire entre le
Sénat et l'Assemblée nationale moi on le
comprend les sénateurs de la droite et
du centre était d'accord pour dire qu'il
y avait bien urgence à développer ses
infrastructures il a donc fait un pas
vers l'exécutif patatras la semaine
dernière le texte est en maintenant
reparti à l'Assemblée nationale on
apprend que les députés cette fois-ci LR
ils ne sont pas d'accord avec les
sénateurs LR le patron de ces députés
annonce qu'il veut réintroduire le droit
de veto des mers quand le texte arrivera
à l'Assemblée nationale écouter Olivier
Marleix très critique c'était hier sur
France Inter
totalement anachronique d'abord sans
répondre à pas aux naufrage de la
politique énergétique nucléaire par les
sénateurs
ça répondra pas à l'urgence de la
situation électrique enfin de
l'électricité en France qui a créé le
président de la République ce texte est
totalement anachronique on fait croire
c'est un moment de communication après
le après la cop27 où on veut avoir de
prendre une initiative c'est un texte
j'allais dire qu'aurait pu prendre
Madame Royal il y a 10 ans quoi
d'ailleurs c'est pas très surprenant en
fait madame borne était sa directrice de
cabinet donc voilà ce texte ce texte
c'est un texte de relance de l'industrie
allemande de l'éolienne et de
l'industrie chinoise du Renault
Photovoltech voilà donc ce texte sur les
ingers renouvelables on a compris était
adopté au Sénat il est donc maintenant
en train d'arriver à l'Assemblée
nationale le gouvernement espère que les
députés LR vont se ranger sur la vie et
des sénateurs et l'air écoutez
Christophe Béchu le ministre de la
transition écologique c'était la semaine
dernière sur notre plateau
les sénateurs sont très proches des élus
municipaux
et il vous a pas échappé qu'ils étaient
ce que je veux dire c'est qui vous a pas
échappé que certains d'entre eux étaient
entrés dans l'hémicycle avec l'idée que
la bonne solution c'était un droit de
veto puis vous avez des associations
d'élus qui ont expliqué pourquoi ça leur
semblait être une mauvaise idée je pense
que quand les républicains à l'Assemblée
nationale vont entrer dans le détail du
texte et vont échanger avec leurs
collègues du Sénat il comprendront
pourquoi c'est une fausse bonne idée
alors justement que ça m'échou qui parle
des mères ça tombe bien le Congrès de
l'Association des maires de France
s'ouvre cette semaine alors la MF est
sur un entre-deux écouter David Lisnard
le président de l'Association des maires
de France ce matin sur notre plateau ce
qu'on avait dit avec la MF c'était de
dire d'abord on n'était pas favorable au
droit de veto en covisibilité parce
qu'au départ il y avait des textes pour
permettre aux maires des communes
voisines de l'installation des
équipements d'exprimer un droit de veto
donc l'AMF a dit non en revanche on ne
veut plus perdre notre pouvoir
d'urbanisme ce qui a été trouvé que
Françoise Gatel à qui on travaille très
bien
c'est de en fait de revenir un peu
personne de développement de l'éolien
mais ce qui n'est pas évident non plus
parce que vous dites dans une commune
voilà le secteur où là on peut mettre
des léoliens voilà on en met pas sur
quels critères pourquoi tel type de
population peut avoir une éolienne pas
très loin alors il y a eu des avancées
dans ce texte importantes et moi je
pense qu'on va trouver un compromis
acceptable à l'Assemblée nationale et au
Sénat alors l'Assemblée nationale le
s'empare de ce texte à partir du 5
décembre prochain problème ça va venir
un petit peu entre choqué comme ça la
présidence du parti LR ce qui va pas
aider pour résoudre l'équation
évidemment ça va compliquer l'expression
merci Quentin on en reparlera évidemment
demain puisqu'on sera en direct en tout
cas depuis le Congrès des Maires de
France Roland Dantec ce compromis qui
était né des discussions au Sénat on le
voit bien il risque pas survivre à la
politisation des débats à l'Assemblée ça
vous désole alors les cops c'est
compliqué et alors le droit de veto des
mers c'est encore plus compliqué qu'une
COP non moi je pense que au Seigneur on
a bien moi j'ai passé un amendement
aussi pour redonner à la région un rôle
de renforcement de visibilité sur
justement ces zones de développement de
l'éolien le texte est pas et pas calé
dans certains articles on parle de zone
prioritaires dans d'autres zones
propices enfin donc il y a besoin de d'y
revenir de mettre le Scott probablement
chez madohérence territoriale plus haut
au cœur de la stratégie mais je crois ce
qu'il faut dire et ça fait écho à notre
discussion précédente qui me semble un
peu inabouti mais elle est compliquée
c'est que ce qui nous manque aujourd'hui
c'est un peu un narratif sur les cops au
delà de dire ça avance ça a reculé ainsi
de suite qu'est-ce qui se passe à
l'échelle mondiale parce que il faut
agir localement j'étais pendant 15 ans
le représentant des un des collectivités
du monde dans les clubs évidemment
l'action aller au niveau local on a une
capacité forte désir et après il faut
contrôler état les grands blocs comme
l'Europe et le monde tout ça sont encore
en ce qui est extrêmement compliqué
puisque avec l'ONU ça fonctionne au
consensus il y a même des guerres
actuellement
et là la taxe carbone aux frontières dit
toutes les grandes économies
mondialisées devront aller sur les mêmes
finalement objectif climat si on veut
que la mondialisation c'est les deux
grands leviers aujourd'hui plus les
enjeux de développement et notamment
vis-à-vis de l'Afrique et merci beaucoup
le cas de la merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat je vois bien que
l'une et l'autre vous oubliez encore
développer les arguments mais bon voilà
les 45 minutes sont écoulés merci encore
faire rien naziari je rappelle le titre
de votre livre les écologistes contre la
modernité c'est publié aux éditions
presse de la cité